we start with an apparent murder-suicide
investigation out of summerlin
this happened at the falling waters
apartments right near town center drive
and summerlin parkway
madison kimbrough joins us now with the
latest developments yes this happened
around 11 this morning as police
responded to a welfare check here at
this apartment complex you see here
falling water apartment homes according
to metro officials a family member from
out of state called in stating that they
had not heard from their parents in over
a week
once police arrived at the apartment
that's when they discovered the bodies
officers arrived at the apartment
complex they noticed an odor coming from
the
apartment we obtained a key from the
manager and upon entering the apartment
we discovered the body
of a male and a female that appeared to
be a murder-suicide
the woman was white and in her mid-50s
no word on the identity of the man or
his age
but according to metro they believe the
woman died first at least a couple days
before the man
they both suffered gunshot wounds to the
head with the mans being self-inflicted
metro says there were no prior
incidences within the last 10 years with
this couple but they do know that they
were suffering from some type of
financial issues
reporting in summerlin madison kimbrough
8 news now